in terms of wisdom
is there mechanisms by which you kind of
observe the negative thoughts and let
them go so you have
uh people like the david goggins who
kind of
this he seems to almost like separate
his mind into
there's the weak david that he hates
and then there's this strong one i mean
there's like a very contentious
relationship there
so he basically says like i refuse to be
that person and he's almost like angry
at that person
it's almost like sometimes literally
yelling at that person
the weak version of themselves and then
there's another more sort of
sam heresy approach which is
like just observe the thought and let it
go
maybe knowing that this too shall pass
like no matter what it this moment will
not last forever and kind of sort of
accepting the natural flow of things and
taking one
step at a time and allowing whatever the
negativity whatever the pain you're
experiencing
just to pass even if it means a death
march
which one is more effective for you
which one like would you say generally
speaking to the population is more
effective
yeah that's a really good question it it
it's probably unique to the individual i
wouldn't argue that
you know david is finding success with
his approach
some may argue it's an extreme version
uh you know sam has obviously thought
about these things and
and uh really probably you know i see
those guys as kind of
two ends of the spectrum and just the
way that they kind of come across
in general where like david's like
really at you kind of high energy and
sam's kind of this calming
soft presence and he's just going to
slowly methodically lay it all out there
and i think there's value on in both of
those i think
most people are probably going to get a
benefit from
pulling some from each i mean there's
times where
where i need a kick in the ass and then
it's like have the strong zack tell the
weak zac to get moving
but there's also times where you know
it's just like
you know a subtle voice entering my head
about you know i don't know if i feel
quite right now should i
maybe pull back on the pace and i think
that
little subtle voice is best approached
with a subtle positive voice where it's
more like
okay well let's think this through here
for a second you're 40 miles into 100
mile race
you spent four months preparing for it
you know from the workouts you did that
you're ready for this there really isn't
any real reason for you to slow down
or to fall off your goal or pace or you
know
reassess what you're doing let's just
give this another mile or two
and then we can reassess if we need to
in in order to kind of figure out if i'm
doing the right things or not
and i think like in that situation um
you definitely probably want to lean
more towards the sam harris approach
with that because there's really no
reason to
it's almost like the same thing you see
with like just
training and even nutrition to a degree
where like some folks they just want to
be
like kind of like drilled they want to
be like
yelled at and said like get going get
doing this and that helps
that motivates and that helps them stay
accountable other people
need some softer love with it where it's
like you know this isn't necessarily
your thought your your fault you were
put in this environment that kind of
created an
atmosphere of lethargy and maybe poor
nutritional choices and things like that
and
and like so but it's it's correctable so
we need to
we need to step away from that and we
need to kind of start heading in the
direction that we know is going to bear
fruit down the road
and that person may respond better to
that so
i think both those guys have great value
with their approaches they're just
probably polar ends of that of the
spectrum and
i think most people are probably going
to benefit like anything right you get
the polarizing ones and those are going
to work right for the polarizing people
but then most people are going to fit
somewhere in the middle so
they're probably going to be able to
kind of pull from both of those if
they're able to sit down and kind of
like
assess which one's going to work better
in which situation
you